The Brother KL 116 Knitleader is a full-
size charting device that's extremely
handy for shaping your knits visually.
With just a few steps,
you'll be creating your own knitting
patterns with very little math.
Here's a listing of machines
that this device can be used with.
The key to using a knitleader  is a Swatch.
For this device, it's critical that you
knit and measure a Swatch 40 stitches
by 60 rows and measure
in the middle of the Swatch.
This is a proper swatch with yarn markers
indicating the stitches in the middle
of the piece and contrasting rows
marking the measurement of the rows.
You can use the metric ruler included with
the knitleader or a standard metric ruler.
Record the measurement
of 40 stitches and 60 rows.
Next, establish the piece that you'll be
knitting and draw or copy a full
size piece for your knitting.
In this example, I'm copying
a sleeve from a sewing pattern.
There was a special pen or a pencil
that came with the machine,
and I'm not sure if these still exist,
but you can test other methods of marking
the Mylar sheet for the knitleader.
Just Mark in the lower corner of the sheet
and test that you can
easily remove the marks.
You're going to reuse
the Mylar over and over.
I'm just using a soft pencil.
I found it came off pretty easily.
I didn't have any tuck with a dry
erase marker, so be careful.
I'll use the sleeve pattern
for the next steps.
Notice that I've lined up the center
of my sleeve along the center
dotted line of the sheet.
This will position the knitting
in the middle of the knitting machine.
You'll want to consider the position
of your stitch pattern
in relation to your knitting.
Remember, punch card machines will
automatically position the stitch
pattern in the middle of the bed.
Plan ahead where you want to position your
stitch pattern based on the
machine that you're using.
Next, attach the knitleader
to your knitting machine.
Slip the setting plates into the slots
at the back of the machine
and slide the knitleader into position so
that the feeding lever engages
with the knitleader row counter tripper.
Now, this is a separate tripper
from the regular machine row counter
tripper. I found on my 260 machine.
I had to remove the accessory cover so
that feeding lever could move cleanly.
Once you have the machine set
up the knitleader in place,
swatch knitted,
your piece drawn on the Mylar,
there are a few steps for putting the knitleader
to work to create
the knitting instructions.
This part of the knitleader
device is called the regulator.
It's a mechanical device
that advances the sheet as you knit.
The regulator is set according to your
gauge and advances the sheet accurately.
For example, if my gauge is 28 rows per
ten centimeters,
setting the regulator correctly,
the sheet will advance 28 times
for every 10 CM of my sleeve.
If my gauge is 15 rows per 10 centimeters,
the regulator will advance 15 times
for every 10 CM of my knitted piece.
The dial on the left allows you
to manually advance or move back rows,
so if you make a mistake and rip out
a few rows, you can move the row
count back on the knitleader.
To set the device to your gauge,
push in and hold the clutch button
and slide the upper and lower
indicators to match your gauge.
This setting indicates a row gauge
of 10.0 CM, and this is a gauge of 20.8
so you set both of the slides.
Remember, the regulator controls
the advancement of the sheet
and reflects the row gauge.
I always think of regulator
R and R for row.
For the stitch gauge,
use the stitch measure scales.
Stitch - scales. The chart in the manual
and the chart that's attached
to the tubular sheet case help you
identify which scale to use
based on your stitch gauge.
If 40 stitches in your Swatch measures 108
mm or 10.8 CM, you would use the
#8 scale aligned to the side
that is marked 108.
Insert the scale in the knitleader
so that 108 side is showing.
If 40 stitches measures 12.5 CM,
use the green #12 scale
with the 125 side showing.
This example,
using this scale, I would have
64 stitches on the needlebed.
Using this scale, there would
be 120 stitches in work.
Big difference.
This is the beauty of using
a charting device.
You can draw your pieces and use them
again and again with different yarns,
different stitch patterns,
and even a different knitting machine.
Make sure you have measured
your gauge correctly.
Set the regulator rows correctly
and selected the correct stitch measure
scales and you're ready to get knitting.
Using the device is visual.
Simply follow the lines
as you're knitting.
The numbers on the scale represent
the needles on the needlebed.
When your drawn line aligns with a number
on the scale, you will increase,
decrease, cast on or bind off stitches.
In other words, you'll
be shaping your piece.
Use your judgment when
the line is between a number.
For example, at this point of shaping
my sleeve cap, needles left 31
through right 30 should be in work.
At this point it would
be left 38 and right 37.
But I would probably choose to knit
my sleeve cap to be symmetrical.
Left 38, right 38, left 37, right 37.
But it's really up to you.
Keep following the line
to shape your garment piece.
Now here's a tip for symmetry.
Just draw half of the design.
In my case, draw half of the sleeve if
it's symmetrical and then
mirror the shaping.
So this works for sleeves
and some garment pieces.
Another trick is to draw one body
shape with multiple necklines.
So here you would have the back neckline.
You could also have your Vneck
line on the same body shape.
It would also speed up the process
of drawing and add to accuracy your
fronts and your back would match.
Another use for a knitleader is to use
it for manually creating stitch patterns.
Think about drawing an Intarsia design right
on the sheet and follow row by row
changing colors as Indicated
once you understand how it works,
this model of knitleader is an easy-
to-use device that can help you quickly
create full-size knitting patterns.